the russian invasion of ukraine has led
more than 400 american companies to shut
down their business connections in
russia but what about those companies
that have not done so we're joined now
by professor jeffrey sonnenfeld the yale
school of management who's been keeping
track of which american companies have
done what and professor thank you for
being here your widely publicized list
has in fact had the effect of pressuring
many companies to exit russia after
first declining to do so
well that's right brian uh thank you
it's a delight to join you
if we didn't expect it would have this
catalytic effect what happened
originally is there were a dozen or so
unexpected firms and oil companies of
all things and and consulting accounting
and lawyers that are professional
service members usually rather jump off
a cliff than engage in any kind of
conflict
thirdly big tech moved up front from the
heavy metal uh device companies of ibm
and dell and apple and things to the to
the social media companies but then all
these pretenders came along uh with
look-alike public relations spin that
were blurring the pretenders with the
authentic uh good guys here so we just
created a list to have an author an
authoritative separation of who's real
and who's fake and at this point what
big companies have refused to pull out
of russia
well you know it's interesting initially
we had a lot of name brands when we
first put
you name it we had every just about
every uh casual dining as they would say
but we would say fast food chain was
there all the hotel industries that were
there and all the fashion companies
usually the consumer goods are on the
leading edge of social change whether or
not it's through the ethics of the
leaders or uh through uh through their
sensitivity to public sentiment but in
this case
our list had this catalytic effect of
celebrating the good guys and there's
sort of a hall of shame but who's left
now there are still some companies in
the u.s cloud fair the a big of course
cloud provider that has some tortured
logic for staying there a company that
uh owns georgia
pacific poke industries you know the
company that makes dixie cups and brawny
towels and great northern uh and angel
soft toilet tissues
they're digging in there in russia and
unapologetic about it it's it's uh it's
quite disappointing to see that and uh
and i think i mentioned that
alibaba and uh some other uh uh
major companies of the uh that you would
think would have the
good sense to pull out but they're using
some kind of a tortured logic of a
humanitarian reason to be there or or a
concern suddenly they see themselves as
paternalistic
employers worried about the long-term
livelihood of their loyal russian
workers when they weren't so worried
about their u.s workforces back before
but it's it's disappointing it's
misleading and cynical professor a
question for you from rhonda schwartz
rhonda
well these are big multinational
companies that presumably can survive
pulling out but what about those workers
what about all those people who lost
their jobs isn't there a real sting
there you know um
if you really have a humanitarian
concern
you would care about
bringing civil society to a standstill
that's how you uh can knock a tyrant
back to scale or even have a government
change this is what of course gandhi did
in india bringing civil society to a
standstill this is what got rid of
nikolaj chesky in romania eric hanukkah
and east germany and poland or even in
ukraine 30 years ago it's by having a
the civil society stop the tyrant the
other other alternative is to go to war
so what's worse for these people that
are complacent and happily employed is
is to uh have western bullets and bombs
dropped on them this we're as there
isn't anybody on any side of this issue
that doesn't admit we're perilously
close to world war iii which would be
catastrophically uh not to be too bleak
for the show but our last war ever it'd
be so horrible so what we're trying to
do is something short of that does that
mean you um
perhaps upset some of the comforts of
the everyday russian yes they're
entirely too complacent there's a good
book by jacob goldhamer called hitler's
willing executioners which pointed out
that the third reich didn't succeed just
because of one cruel tyrant but in fact
it was the complacency of the german
public in this case enough already by
saying all
propaganda when they are identified as a
rogue nation by all the countries in the
world with their major
professor what big companies do you
think are about to pull out who could
have a a devastating impact that's still
in there
now if if uh we could see some of the
major grain companies that have put out
some companies like archer daniels
midland uh and uh uh cargill that would
have a big impact because they're
certainly a part of the bread basket of
europe they're in there we give them a d
around a 7f rating because they're
putting off some long-term investments
we don't know what they are it would
matter a lot if they pulled out same
with the oil servicing firms
schlumberger
or
baker hughes
or halliburton it would matter a lot if
they were to pull out but right now
they're digging in there with some
public relations smoke screen that we've
had to acknowledge to elevate them from
an f grade to a d
professor i noticed you also a man after
my own heart you went after your own
educational institutions with their
connections to russia over the years
yes brian we do share that in common is
that you and i both wherever we see it
and uh sometimes it gets us both into
trouble for doing it in this case mit
wasn't too happy but yale was thrilled
is that there was a time where these
oligarchs which is very recent past
circling around all universities to try
to cleanse uh their wealth with the
stature of many institutions and well we
identified back in 2018 i pointed out
who these people were and i was happy
that yale cleanly and quickly got out
mit not the same thing they told me i
worked with them privately back in 2018
and they got in a huge way hundreds of
millions of dollars hidden as they were
taking money to prop up what is sort of
a
kind of a fake university that was doing
some pretty scary research that mit was
working on with them that gets
perilously close to the national defense
issues and i i won't bore you to tear to
tears on the technology of it all but
it's things that no u.s university
should have been giving to the russians
for professor jeffrey sunfield you're on
the case from the yale school of
management thank you so much for being
with us here tonight
thank you i'm most honored coming up
next this week's winners and losers in
the media see if you agree with the
editors of media what they had to say
about comedian jon stewart not so good
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week's winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaide and we're joined by
aidan mclaughlin who's the
editor-in-chief of mediai which like the
law and crime trial network is part of
the dan abrams media group and aiden
you've chosen as the winner this week in
the aftermath of the big slap at the
oscars sarah seidner of cnn let's see
what she had to say
i have to be honest i'm a little
embarrassed that i'm even talking about
this right now we've got inflation that
is crushing families we have millions of
refugees who are running for their lives
trying to find refuge
mothers and children and we've got
ukraine which is literally on fire and
being bombed
so agency put it very much in context
right and i think she said what a lot of
us are thinking this week uh i i should
point out that sarah seidner she is a
cnn uh senior national and international
correspondent she's reported from as far
as jerusalem abu dhabi los angeles and
now she's back in new york she also just
returned from reporting on the russian
invasion of ukraine in eastern europe
particularly the the refugee crisis
there so it's not surprising that she
would look at the story like the oscars
slap and see it as slightly less
important than what's going on in
ukraine and elsewhere
i do want to say that we shouldn't be
too serious about it obviously will
smith slapping
chris rock at the oscars is a big story
we should cover it we should revel in it
but i think considering what's going on
and considering what this cnn
correspondent has been covering over the
past couple weeks uh her comments really
rang true for a lot in the media and
overall the media covered it quite a bit
that's true i think it was the top story
on almost every show on cable news on
monday so there was no shortage of
coverage of it
and i i'd say that sarah seidner as far
as i know is one of the only journalists
who pushed back on that
and for this week's loser you chose uh
jon stewart tell us why jon stewart the
comedian
so jon stewart uh has his new show on
apple tv it's called the problem with
jon stewart and he had a pretty odd i
would say segment on his show this week
where he discussed systemic racism in
america with
three guests all of whom are white um
now one of those guests is a woman by
the name of lisa bond who
became famous uh in the last couple
years for
throwing these dinners where and i'm not
joking here
women pay thousands of dollars to be
told that they are racist and
we explained why to them that they are
racist um she's kind of known as one of
the more
griftier of the anti-racism consultants
out there and for some reason jon
stewart thought that she would be a good
voice to have on this panel to discuss
uh systemic racism in america she got in
a big argument with andrew sullivan who
is a
fairly controversial writer at least on
the on the topic of race
but she didn't confront any of his
arguments she dismissed him as racist
and said that she didn't even want to
have a conversation with another white
man all right let's see what happened
and i did not come on this on this show
to sit here and argue with another white
man that's one of the reasons that we
don't even engage with white men at race
to dinner
if i could finger snap i would finger
snap right now
uh
let's remove it now i'm not calling me a
rapist
let's you're you've been doing a pretty
good job with yourself there
and for that you say jon stewart was
quite the loser right i mean that that
sort of rhetoric is expected from
someone like lisa bond who again is a
sort of anti-racism consultant uh what's
disheartening is to not only hear jon
stewart's audience applaud her for those
kind of comments but jon stewart to also
agree with her about it um i think it's
particularly disheartening for people
watching and particularly people who are
fans of the daily show what a surprise
though for jon stewart as a loser that's
a surprise for a lot of people who think
he's great right and you know his show
which uh debuted recently on apple tv
has not been getting a lot of attention
this is one of the first times i think
that i've seen a segment from it really
go viral
on twitter and it's mainly because of
those comments um you know i'm not
defending anything that uh that andrew
sullivan said on the show he argued that
uh systemic racism does not exist and is
not a problem in america um but i think
the conversation was particularly
unproductive because of the arguments
made by lucidbloom there so this was a
stumble you think for jon stewart yeah i
think he should probably get better
bookers on his show unlike the booker's
uh that we have here so he's looking for
an audience and he's yet to really find
one i guess right i mean we don't know
what the audience is but given it's
apple tv they don't really release stats
uh in terms of their audience um but uh
i have not really seen much hype around
this show all right aidan mclaughlin
thank you so much for being here and
thanks for all of you for watching we'll
see you again here next week on the law
and crime trial network
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you